ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทั้ง 8
คนของเรา
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทั้ง 8 คนของครูหญิง
แล้วก็ครูเอ๋เอ๋ค่ะเรามีนักเรียนทั้งหมด
ยังอยู่ที่ 8 คน
ใช่ค่ะ 8 คนนะคะนะคะสวัสดีค่ะคุณแม่แอ๊ด
ครูเอ๋คะคุณแม่ตัว a
วันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันอะไรกับผู้หญิงมัน
อะไรนะคะผู้หญิงวันวันอาทิตย์
[เพลง]
วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 13 ค่ะวันอาทิตย์
วันที่ 13 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
มีนาคมค่ะเดือนมีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพต
565 ค่ะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศต.ยคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะปีคศ 2  022 นะคะแล้วตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
10:37 นาทีค่ะเวลา
10:37 นาทีนะคะหากนักเรียนนอนตื่นๆก็นัก
เรียนบางคนกำลังจะ
[เพลง]
นักเรียนตื่นแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋แล้วใช่ไหมคะ 10
โมงเนี่ยครูเนี่ยตื่นแต่คิดนักเรียนกำลัง
ก็อยากจะนอน
นักเรียนตื่นแล้วค่ะตื่นนะตื่นนะคะ
โอเคค่ะครูหญิงคะนักเรียนของเราเหมือน
เหมือนเหมือน
เมื่อวานมี 8 คนเมื่อวานครูเอ๋กับครูหญิง
น่ะนะก็พูดถามนักเรียนว่านักเรียนอะไรคะ
แต่งแต่ง
แต่งงานนะคะ
ค่ะ
แต่นั้นแต่แต่งงาน
หรือ
โสดหา
โซเบียคนเดียวอ้ะนักเรียนบางคนแต่งงานค่ะ
แต่บางคนโสดบางคนมีแฟน
มีแฟน
บางคนมั่นค่ะมีแหวนแล้วก็มั่นนะคะ
วันนี้ครูเอ๋มีคำถามอีก
โอ้วันนี้ครูเอ๋เอ๋ถามนักเรียน 8 คนอีก
หรอคะใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋มีคำถามนะคะ
ตัว A มีคำถามผู้หญิงเขียนคำถามให้กลัว
เอดส์ได้ไหมคำถามนะ
ครูเอ๋มีคำถามนะคะค่ะครูเอ๋อยากรู้
วันนี้ครูเอ๋เอ๋อยากรู้อะไร
ครูเอ๋เอ๋อยากรู้นักเรียน
มีอาชีพ
อารัยโห
[เพลง]
นะคะครูหญิงครูหญิงมีอาชีพอะไรคะใครหญิง
พูดบางทีพูดทำอาชีพอะไร
มีอาชีพอะไรทำอาชีพอะไรโอเคผู้หญิงทำ
อาชีพอะไรคะครูหญิงทำอาชีพครูค่ะห้ามผู้
หญิงทำอาชีพครู
นักเรียนคะเวลามีคำถามอันเนี้ยมีอาชีพ
อะไรทำอาชีพอะไร
อาชีพอะไรโอเคไหมโอเคอ้า
ครูหญิงอาชีพอะไรนะ
ผู้หญิงอาชีพครูค่ะครูหญิงอาชีพครูนะคะ
อ่ะ
คุณครูเอ๋ราคาครูเอ๋อีกทำอาชีพอะไรครูเอ๋
อาชีพนักร้องนัก
ร้องเอาไม่ใช่ไม่โทรเอ๋ไม่ได้ทำอาชีพนัก
ร้องอ๋อครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ทำอาชีพนักร้องครูเอ๋
ก็
อาชีพครูค่ะพี่เอ๋
อาชีพครูนะคะหรือบางทีพูดครูเอ๋เป็นครู
หนาค่ะครูต้อมผู้หญิงก็เป็นครูเหมือนครู
เอ๋
สองคนเป็นครูเหมือนกันนะคะแม้คุณแบรด
คุณแม้คนแบบนี้อิ่มอีกแล้วคุณแบบยิ้มคุณ
แบรดคะคุณ Black อาชีพ
ว่าไงคะคุณ
แม็คทำอาชีพอะไรคะผู้หญิงดูซิคุณแม่ผู้
หญิงเอียดคุณแม่เขียนที่กระดาษค่ะกระดาษ
อ่ะแบตไม่ต้องพูดนะคะคุณนัทดูฟังเราก็มี
ปากกากระดาษแล้วเขียนค่ะเขียนแล้วก็ยกให้
ครูหญิงดูนะคะ
คุณแบรสต์ยกกระดาษแล้วค่ะคุณแบรคคุณแบรด
ยกกระดาษคุณแบรดบอกว่าทำอาชีพอะไรคะครู
หญิงคุณแบรคทำอาชีพพ่อครัวค่ะคุณ Bad ทำ
อาชีพเพราะคลิปพ่อครัวอันนี้ใช่ไหมคะพ่อ
ครัวไทยค่ะดู of คุณแบตคุณ Bag ทำอาชีพ
และครอบครัวเราก็พูดว่าคุณ mad เป็นพ่อ
ครัว
ใส่ค่ะถ้ามีคนถามคุณ Bad ทำอาชีพอะไรคุณ
แม้ต้องพูดว่าอะไรคะผม
ผมเป็นพ่อครัว
ผมก็คือคุณ mad ใช่ไหมคะ
Black เป็นผู้ชายอาจคุณแม้แต่คน Bag ผู้
หญิงเขียนไม่วาดรูปคุณแม้แต่แล้วก็มีอีก
หนึ่งคนนะคะมีพูดว่าอีกหนึ่งคนอ่ะ
มีผู้หญิงถามคุณ mad คุณ Bad ทำอาชีพอะไร
คะ
เป็นคนรอสคุณแรส Copy กุญแจใช่ไหมคะให้
ขุดผมทำอาชีพพ่อครัว
หรือพูดว่าถ้าผมเป็นพ่อครัวโอเค
โอเคเหมือนกันถามใหม่นะคุณ Bag ทำทำอาชีพ
อะไรคะ
ผมเป็นพ่อครัวครับคุณแม็กก็ตอบผมเป็นพ่อ
ครัวนะคะหนูโอเคอันนี้คุณแบตเป็นพ่อครัว
โอ๋
คิดว่าคุณแบบทำ
อาหารเก่ง
ไหนบอกใช่ใช่ค่ะคู๋ร้อน
V ร้อนแอร์ใช่ไหมมีพื้นนักเรียนดูแอร์ใน
คะ Air  crew
โอเคเดี๋ยวนะคะค่ะ
คุยยกกล้องให้ดูแอร์ก่อนพิมพ์ไม่อ่ะอุ้ย
ไม่ใช่แต่เห็นแล้วค่ะแอคพี่เก๋แก
ไม่ดี
รอง
ราคาร้อน
โอเคคุณ Bag เป็นพ่อครัวนะคะใส่ค่ะมี
อาชีพพ่อครัวโอเคค่ะกินคะคะครูเอ๋อยากรู้
อยากรู้ใครดีอยากรู้ใคร
เอาคุณใครนะอ๋อ
คุณนิซ่าแล้วกันคุณลิซ่ามาโคร Lisa เป็น
ผู้หญิงนะคะผู้หญิงไปหวันนะคะ
คุณลิซ่าคะคุณวีซ่าทำอาชีพอะไรคะก็คุณลิ
ซ่าตยกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋นะคะคุณนี้ใช่ยก
บอกว่าอาชีพอะไรคะคุณลิซ่ายกคุณลิซ่าทำ
อาชีพจะรีบพยาบาลค่ะ
คุณลิซ่าทำอาชีพพยาบาล
นี่เม็ด
[เพลง]
พยาบาลพยาบาลนะคะอุ้ยเสียพยาบาลเด็กๆนะคะ
นิพยาบาลเปิดผู้หญิงคะถ้ามีอะครูหญิงเป็น
คุณลิซ่าครูเอ๋เป็นครูเอ๋
แล้วก็มีอ่ะ
คู๋มีคำถามคุณลิซ่าคูนิสอ้าทำอาชีพอะไร
คุณลิซ่าต้องพูดอะไรคะอ่ะฉันฉันเป็น
พยาบาลค่ะคุณลิซ่าเป็นผู้หญิง
สำหรับผู้หญิงไม่พูดผมรู้วัดคุณแล้นคุณ
แร้คเป็นผู้ชายค่ะผู้ชายพูดอะไรคะ
แต่ผม
คุณแม็คทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
ผมเป็นพ่อครัวคุณแร๊ดพ่อครัวครับใช่มั้ย
รับพระคน Lisa  Lisa เป็นพยาบาลอ่ะครู
เอ๊ะถามว่าคุณลิซ่า
ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
ฉันเป็นพยาบาลค่ะฉันเป็นพยาบาลขอบคุณ Lisa
เป็นพยาบาลนะสวัสดีค่ะ
ขอบคุณค่ะ
ต่อไปค่ะกูหญิงครูเอ๋อยากรู้คุณ
โรเบิร์ตทำอะไรคะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตบอกว่าบอกว่าอะไรคะคุณรอ
เบิร์ตทำอาชีพนักบินค่ะนับ in ก็ต้องมี
เครื่องบินไหมผู้หญิงไฟฟ้าเครื่องบินส
อ่า
[เพลง]
อันนี้คนระเบิดอันนี้เก้าอี้ใช่ไหมคะคุณ
Robert นั่งตรงไหนก็ระเบิดนั่งข้างหน้า
หม้อหน้าจงนี้แล้วก็คุณโรเบิร์ตก็
มีอะไรเนี่ย
คุณมาเปิดนั่งข้างหน้านะคะช่างน่าเรื่อง
ดินคุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นนักบินค่ะชายนี่กุล
Robert โอ้คุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นนะบินและเห็น
ไหมคะเห็นเนาะเห็นนิทานครูเอ๋นี่เก้าอี้
ใช่มั้ยเก้าอี้แล้วก็มีอะไรคะคันโยก
คันโยกแล้วก็มีหูใช่ไหมหูฟังหูฟังนะคะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นนักบินคน
หน้าที่บางทีพูดทับศัพท์ภาษาอังกฤษไหม
พูดภาษาอังกฤษเนาะบางทีใครบางพูดนักบิน
บางทีพูดกัปตันหาทรายค่ะอ๋อคุณโรเบิร์ตก็
พูดได้ผมเป็นนักบิน
ได้หรือ
OS ถามคนระเบิดมีอาชีพอะไรคะตัวเองถามคน
ระเบิดก็บอกผมเป็นนักบินครับคุณโรเบิร์ต
ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
ผมเป็นกัปตันครับโอเค
ได้ 2 อย่างนั้นผมเป็นนักบินครับผมเป็น
กัปตันครับโอเคมาขาโอเคอ่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณ
ต่อไป
ครูเอ๋อยากรู้ใครคะอ่ะคุณคุณระเบิดอังกฤษ
ใช่ไหมคะเอาหรือเปล่าค่ะคุณธนาชิคะคุณ
ทาดาชิทำอาชีพอะไรคะพ่อคุณป้าได้ซิยกแล้ว
มึงเคยนินทาดาและคุณคทาได้บอกว่าทำอาชีพ
อะไรคะคุณชาดาชิบอกว่าทำอาชีพหมอค่ะ
คุณดาใจถ้าราชิเป็นหมอ
ใช่ค่ะ
นี่บ่อ๋อ
นี่ไก่เสื้อสีขาวใช่ป่ะใกล้ค่ะนะตรงนี้
อะไรคะครูหญิงหูเลยนะคะหูฟังหูฟังหูใช่
ไหมใส่แล้วก็ฟังที่นี่มีหัวใจๆๆๆจุ๊บๆๆๆ
เป็นหมอแล้วก็มีเด็กหมอไม่สบายใช่มะเด็ก
ไม่สบายเอาอันนี้มีเตียง
ขายเตียงเห็นไหมคะนักเรียนก็เห็นแล้วค่ะ
มีปีเรียงนะคะอันนี้หูฟังของหมอหมอแล้วก็
เด็กนะคะเด็กทำอะไรคะผู้หญิงเด็กนั่งอยู่
ค่ะเด็กนั่งคุณหมอราคา
คุณหมอเนี่ยฟังหัวใจคุณหมอฟังหัวใจเด็ก
คุณหมอยืนหรือนั่งคะคุณหมอนั่งค่ะคุณหมอ
นั่งคุณทานาชิ
เป็นคุณหมอรึฮะอะถึงถ้าครูเอ๊ะถามคุณทาชิ
คุณธนชิตทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุณภาระทิศต้องพูด
อะไรคะ
ผมเป็นหมอครับผมเป็นหมอนะครับใครเป็น
พยาบาลครูหญิงอ่ะอาริซ่าคุณลิซ่า
คุณบินลิสคุณลิซ่าเป็นพยาบาลนะคะอ่ะคุณ
ธาราชิเป็นหมอ
หมอกับพยาบาลทำงานที่ไหนคะครูหญิง
หมอหมอกับพยาบาลทำงานที่โรงพยาบาลค่ะ
หมอ
กับพยาบาล
นะทำงานที่โรงพยาบาลโอเคเองขอบคุณค่ะครู
หญิง
ใครอีก
ครูเอ๋อยากรู้คุณ John คะคุณ John คุณ
John อเมริกาคุณ John ชุด
คุณ John ยกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋คุณ John มึงจร
คะทำอาชีพอะไรคุณ John โยคุณผู้หญิงคุณ
จอนบอกว่าทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุณจอนบอกว่าคุณ
John ทำอาชีพนักธุรกิจ
อัญนี้ไหม
ใช่ค่ะนักธุรกิจนักธุรกิจมีอะไรคะผู้หญิง
มีคอมพิวเตอร์มีคอมพิวเตอร์ราคาแล้วมี
อะไรอีกคะ
โทรศัพท์ค่ะค่ะมีโทรศัพท์มี
ปะกำขับ
มีอะไรกระดาษปากกาแล้วก็กระดาษมีเกิดเก๋
เฮ้ยนี่คือ
กระดาษกระดาษ
มีมีกระดาษเมตรถ้ามีมีอะไรคะปากกามีปากกา
นะคะผมขอคุณ John อ่าอ่ะเป็นนักธุรกิจผู้
หญิงผู้หญิงเป็นคุณ John ครูเอ๋ถาม
คุณ John คะคุณ John ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณจอนบอกอาจผมเป็นนักธุรกิจครับเมื่อคุณ
จะตลอดผมเป็นนักธุรกิจ
พุ่งมีคอมพิวเตอร์
โอเค
ต่อไป
คุณประวีณา
ปวีณา
ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณตารีนายกนะค่ะครูเอ๋ถ้าคุณปวีณาบอกว่า
ว่าทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุณปวีณาทำอาชีพจิตรกร
ค่ะคุณปวีณาเป็นดิบจะก๊อนท์เดี๋ยวเนื้อหา
ก่อนคุยมีอะไรค่ะมันไหมที่สกอร์น่ากลัว A
มี
แต่ก่อน
ใส่ค่ะจิตรกรถืออะไรคะถือพู่กันค่ะหรือ
ผู้กันแล้วมือนี้ถืออะไรคะจานสีค่ะการสี
หน้าในจานสีมีอะไรคะมีสีค่ะนิดมีสีแล้วก็
ทิศโต๊ะอันนี้เป็นโต๊ะนะคะโต๊ะโต๊ะมีอะไร
คะมีหลอดสีค่ะหลอดสีนะคะจิตรกรก็จะบีบใช่
ไหมบีบสี
ใส่ใส่ลายจานสีหาอาจารย์สีเค้าจะบี่
แล้วก็ใช้พู่กัน
ป้ายสี
แก่แล้วทำอะไรอะมีอะไรถ้ากูหญิงอันนี้
อะไรนะคะ Came  and  Frame บางคนไทยก็พูด
แผ่นเฟรมบางทีพูดแผ่นค่าใช่มั้ยรู้เป็น
ผ้าอันเนี้ยถ้านะครับค่าแบบค่าอันนี้สี
ขาวค่ะสีขาว
จิตรกร
ทำอะไรคะครูหญิง
ระบายสีใช่ไหมคะว่าวาดวาดภาพจิตรกรวาดภาพ
จิตรกรระบายสีโอเคนะคะคุณประวีณาทำอาชีพ
อะไรนะคะผู้หญิง 7 รักคุณประวีณาทำอาชีพ
จิตรกรค่ะถ้าครูเอ๋ถาม
นายทวีหน้าคุณปวีณาทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุณปวีณา
พูดสั้นๆว่าอะไรคะฉันเป็นจิตกรค่ะฉันเป็น
จิตรกรนะคะโอเค
ต่อไป
รู้เหยาอยากรู้ใคร
คุณ
shashi ค่ะหลักคนแท้ฮี่คุณแท้ที่คุณแทง
คะคุณแทฮีทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณแพ้บอกว่าคุณแทงอะไรคะคุณแทฮีทำ
อาชีพ
ตำรวจค่ะตำรวจตำรวจเอมี่
อวด
ดีหากคุณแทฮีเป็นตำรวจตำรวจจะใส่อะไรคะ
ผู้หญิง
ใส่หมวกค่ะค่ะใส่หมวกใส่หมวดนะคะตำรวจชุด
อันนี้ตำรวจไทยตำรวจไทยตำรวจไทยชุดสีอะไร
คะ
ตำรวจไทยชุดสีน้ำตาลค่ะตำรวจไทยชุดสีน้ำ
ตาลนะคะ
คนสุดท้ายค่ะครูเอ๋ถ้าครูเอ๋ถามคุณแจฮี
คุณแตฮีคู๋ถามคุณแปลงดีคุณ patchy มี
อาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณแตฉีดต้องพูดอะไรคะ
ผมเป็นตำรวจครับง่อขอบคุณค่ะคุณแตฮี
ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิงคู๋อยากรู้คือคุณ John
สวีเดนค่ะคุณ John คุณ John ทำอาชีพอะไร
คะคุณจอห์นไม่คุณ John ยุคแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋
555 คุณจอนบอกว่าทำอาชีพอะไรคะครูหญิง
คุณ John ทำอาชีพ
ช่างเครื่องค่ะ
คุยหากันช่างเครื่องมีมั้ย
อ๋อ
คุณ John ทำอาชีพช่างเครื่องนะคะ
กอดคุณจออันนี้เป็นเครื่องราคาเครื่องละ
ก็อันนี้เป็นชุดช่างราคาโออันนี้มี
ล้อมแบงค์รถ
- ใช่ไหมคะแล้วคุณจอห์นเป็นสร้างเครื่อง
รถเรืองนะคะช่างเครื่องคือคุณ John ถือ
ถืออะไรอ่ะคืออะไรอ่ะครูเอ๋รู้ไหมคะอัน
นี้เรียกประแจ
แล้วอีกมือหนึ่งล่ะคะเรียกอะไรไขควงไหม
อ่ะใส่ใส่สักไขควงอันนี้ประแจอันนี้ไขควง
นะคะนี่เป็นเครื่องนะคะเครื่องเครื่อง
ยนต์ของรถเนาะอ๋ออ๋อคุณชรคุณจอห์น
เป็นช่างเครื่องผู้หญิงคะผ้าครูเอ๋ถามคุณ
John คุณ John คะคุณ John ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
คุณ John พูดอะไรคะ
ผมเป็นช่างเครื่องครับ
ขอบคุณค่ะคุณ John
ครูหญิง Heart วันนี้เราก็รู้
เมื่อนักเรียนทำอาชีพอะไรอ่ะนักเรียนทำ
อาชีพอะไรบ้างคะค่ะคุณ
แบลชนะคะคุณแร้คุณแมทท์ทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุณ
Black เป็นพ่อครัวค่ะ
add เป็นพ่อครัวราคามีคนต่อไปค่ะคุณโร
เบิร์ตคุณ loher ทำอาชีพอะไรคะครูหญิงคุณ
โรเบิร์ตเป็นนักบินค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นนะ
บินครูเอหา
หานักบินคุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นนักบินค่ะเป็น
กัปตันนะคะขอใช้คุณโรเบิร์ตเนี่ยพูดได้ 2
ค่ะ
พูดได้ว่าเป็นอะไรคะคุณโรเบิร์อยากเป็น
นักบินค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตเป็นกัปตัน
เคแล้วคุณทาชินะคะผู้หญิงคุณทาดาชิทำ
อาชีพอะไรคะอ๋อคุณทาดาชิเป็นหมอค่ะคุณธนา
ชิเป็นหมออากาศเป็นหนี้ผู้หญิงคุณ John
สุ Master เป็นทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุยหาก่อนคุณ
John คุณจอห์นเป็นนักธุรกิจค่ะคุณจอห์น
เป็นนักธุรกิจนะคะนั่นมีคอมพิวเตอร์มี
โทรศัพท์ได้
คุณลิซ่านะคะผู้หญิงคนลิซ่าทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
น้องหรอคุณลิซ่าเป็โรงพยาบาลค่ะเป็น
พยาบาลนะคะพยาบาลมีหมวด
สีขาวนะคะค่ะผู้หญิงแล้วคุณประวีณานะคะ
คุณประวีณาทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุณประวีณาเป็น
จิตกรค่ะคุณประเวลาเป็นจิตรกรวาดรูปนะคะ
วาดรูป
ผู้หญิงคะคุณ
คนเกาหลีคุณแท้ที่
คุณแท้ทำอาชีพอะไรคะคุณแทฮีเป็น
ตำรวจถ่าขุนแผนมีเป็นตำรวจ
คนสุดท้ายคุณจอห์นอร็คมีการโอน of ทำ
อาชีพอะไรคะครูหญิง
คุณจอห์นเป็นช่างเครื่องค่ะคุณจอห์นเป็น
ช่างเครื่อง
ผู้หญิงกับครูเอ๋ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
ครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋เป็นครูค่ะครูหญิงกับครู
เอ๋เป็นครู
อะไรเรามีนักเรียนในคลาส 8 คนค่ะถ้ามีนัก
เรียนนักเรียนที่ดูครูหญิงดูครูเอ๋ฟังครู
หญิงฟังครูเอ๋ทำอาชีพอะไรคะ
ครูเอ๋ถามนักเรียนหรอคะหน้าครูเอ๋เอ๋ถาม
ว่านักเรียนนักเรียนที่ดูฟังครูหญิงครู
เอ๋
มีอาชีพอะไร
น้อถ้าอะนักเรียนตอบก็คอมเม้นข้างล่าง
มีอาชีพนี้ไหมคะโป๊อันนี้อาชีพอะไรคะครู
เอ๋
นักบินอวกาศ
มีใครพูดมนุษย์มนุษย์
มนุษย์อวกาศ
มีอาชีพเป็นมนุษย์อวกาศมีไหมคะ
หน้ามีไม่มีให้มี
โอเคค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักอาชีพนะคะ
สารที่ปรูก็อยากรู้นะเรียนอาชีพอะไรนะคะ
คลิปนี้หมดเวลาแล้วดูหญิงหนูโอเคก็เจอกัน
คุณแม่ราคาหน้านะคะเจอกันวันนี้ครูหญิง
กับครูเอ๋บ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายสวัสดีสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย
บ๊ายบายๆ